Google Friend Connect is launching deeper
integration with Twitter. Now, through Twitter,
friend connect sites can reach millions more
users.
With these new updates, you can sign on to
any friend connect site using your Twitter
ID.
When you click to sign in, you first enter
your information with Twitter, then they send
it back to Friend Connect. Then, your Twitter
picture and name are displayed.
You can invite your Twitter followers to check
out the site at the time that you join. Without
leaving the site, you can tweet about your
new membership and include a link. Just like
on twitter!
Likewise, you can invite followers to the
site at any other time, by clicking the "invite"
link in the members gadget.
You can also tweet when you post a comment
to a discussion on the site. So if there is
an interesting conversation, you can let other's
know about it.
All of your tweets are instantly broadcast
to your followers
For site owners, the best part is that you
don't need to do anything. If you already
run a FriendConnect-enabled site, this just
works.
To get started using friend connect on your
site, visit http://www.google.com/friendconnect/